the uk is no stranger to heat waves but
temperatures are climbing unusually high
for this time in the summer
so who needs santorini when you have
skegness
the uk hotter than some greek islands on
the country's hottest day of the year so
far
with friday set to break the record
again
i don't mind the hot weather i like with
the sun i love the sunshine but i don't
like the heat this is lovely like this
with a bitter shade get me some cream on
and whatever and chill out
could be hot
i love it i would i must admit i would
like it to be hotter you've got me
mindful when you're with the little ones
definitely um i tend to let him have as
many icelanders as he wants to have
throughout the day it's been horrendous
two years for everybody and it's nice to
see everybody enjoying themselves
it's nearly 50 years since the country's
highest june temperature that was here
in southampton's mayflower park when in
1976 it hit
35.6 degrees
now temperatures aren't expected to get
quite as high as that this week but not
far off with highs of around 34 degrees
very rare for this time of year now as
we know uk summers have got hotter due
to climate change but it's also
increased the likelihood we'll see
extreme temperatures during heat waves
the early summer heat may be great news
for some but as ever it's a concern for
farmers crops and the elderly a level
three heat health alert issued for
central and southern england to warn the
public of the dangers
it is extremely serious particularly
because it increases cardiovascular
morbidity and mortality it interrupts
sleep it can also impair cognitive
performance and
there are studies that show how extreme
heat are associated with increased risks
of suicide and hospital admissions
the high temperatures will be over by
sunday but some experts are linking the
intense june heat to climate change
so it could well be a sign of what's to
come as uk summers get hotter
sally lockwood sky news southampton